how dangerous of the tech giants in your
VM it was really interesting as you were
doing your your introduction I was
reminded when I started my first
internet business in the 90s it was
exactly that Golden Age you know and it
was a whole bunch of rather strange
maverick people doing something just to
see what we could do right and it was
very very striking and super noticeable
that at some point it became clear that
among all the other cool stuff we could
do we could make a ton of money at which
point a whole new population descended
upon us you know I had people in ties
applying for jobs I mean it was
mind-blowing because they were really
different with really different motives
yeah and you know so I suspect now we'd
say that's the my you know the
transition from Internet 1.0 to 2.0 and
I don't know where we are now but it
definitely it changed it changed from a
kind of really kind of funky niche
experiment to something whose scale we
didn't appreciate but definitely some
people appreciated the potential
economic scale that was involved I think
you know there are a couple of things I
would say about this one is I think what
you're seeing from the tech companies
themselves is a really epic scale of
bystander behavior right there are a lot
of companies running around saying
something must be done
nobody is by somebody out there right so
we recognize there are problems but
they're not our problems they're bigger
than us so they're not ours and I heard
the CEO of Amazon UK the other day say
you know we think GD Pompeians
marvellous and what a shame it wasn't
earlier what a shame government isn't
doing more because we think of a real
framework would economically be better
but then they don't do a thing except
carry on collecting data and using it
and proudly announcing that people who
have alexa's the buy more toothpaste
through Amazon so that's great they
figured out a terrific incredibly
complicated way to sell toothpaste but
you know but it's not their problem it's
not their problem so I think that
is a problem in and of itself the
ignorance of politicians on this front
is jaw-dropping at one point I was
summoned to an audience with Harriet
Harman to discuss technology and I
explained how you know if she really
wanted to understand this she needed to
talk to a much broader range of people
apologies if this seems like an attack
it isn't but you know she was I said you
know you have to talk to more people
than Google and she said but Google's so
dazzling it's like well what kind of
answer is that right she had just been
completely dazzled what she hadn't done
was thought actually this stuff's really
important and I really need to
understand it and if I can't understand
it I need some people around me who
really do and I have encountered this
with a very large number of politicians
who sort of think well something must be
done but they don't really understand it
oh it's so complicated and it raters my
brain hurt and it's probably young
people will understand it and so you
have this phenomenal passing of the buck
which is which is shocking and a real
dereliction and then you have from the
tech community or the tech business
community which I think sometimes is
different a very interesting rhetoric of
speed which is you get nonsense like
people say you know we're having more
change faster than any other generation
in history has ever known and it's all
coming so fast and we're gonna have
driverless cars everywhere in five years
and there is no time to think because it
really behooves us not to think we know
we would prefer that you not be thinking
about this because then we can get on
with it so I think there's a kind of
artificial and artificially induced
panic to persuade us to just you know
really lie down and play dead and you
know and that's what a lot of the
prediction nonsense is which is
propaganda trying to persuade you
there's no time left the game's over
just suck it up and I think that I would
say just to
the things very very quickly one is that
of course encouraging populations to do
nothing is really pretty easy and it
James's point about attention you know
if you can dazzle them with kittens and
puppets you know that's even easier so
this is troubling in its
authoritarianism and the other thing I
would say is that the language of the
tech community by and large is
obfuscating which is we don't talk about
people anymore we talk about data we
don't talk about rules anymore we talk
about algorithms you know that the more
we can abstract this the more we become
blind to the very human very moral
consequences of it and I think when you
have a combination of enormous economic
power a spectacular misuse of language a
huge amount of propaganda in this
language of speed yeah you have a very
very big problem with our democratic
institutions need to be doing more to
confront did you know that the Institute
of arson ideas also has a podcast
philosophy for our times brings you the
biggest ideas from the leading thinkers
around the world every week search for
philosophy for our times and subscribe
today on your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode